hello my name is elaine vaughn and i'm
here to show you ways to accelerate
validation during the pandemic
my background in process engineering
facilities utilities equipment
qualification
cleaning sterilization and process
validation gives me the unique
perspective to introduce tools for
accelerating validation activities
during the pandemic and ideally post
pandemic as well
let's get started
step on the ass let's accelerate
validation during the pandemic
first we're going to give you a little
overview i have validation 101
then we're going to talk about
paper-based validation
followed by paperless software-based
validation
and software options in comparison
so validation 101 why validate
a historical perspective i can offer is
the 1937
elixir sulfonamide incident that
precipitated the formation of our modern
fda
sulfonamide was used to treat strep
throat infections using a powder or
tablet
in 1937 the elixir was reformulated for
ease of dosing to pediatric and elderly
patients but yet used by adults as well
but only flavor appearance and fragrance
were evaluated
the formulation chemist used diethylene
glycol which is antifreeze and poisonous
to dissolve sulcinamide into solution in
1937 it was not illegal to use toxic
ingredients and formulations
the fda laws did not prohibit dangerous
untested or poisonous drugs
in a quote from carol valentine's
publication in 1981
called the fda consumer magazine she
said by the 1930s it was widely
recognized that the food and drug act of
1906 was obsolete
but bitter disagreement arose as to what
should replace it
by 1937 most of the arguments had been
resolved
but congressional action was stalled
then came the shocking development
the deaths of more than a hundred people
after using a drug that was clearly
unsafe that's this sulfidimide elixir
the incident hastened the final
enactment of in 1938 of the federal food
drug and cosmetic act
the statute that today remains the basis
for fda regulation of these products
in the usa the fda ensures safety of our
foods drugs and medical devices and
cosmetics
there are many other regulatory bodies
as well that ensures safety of these
products worldwide
in the u.s the pharmaceutical regulation
requirements are
21 cfr part 211
and 21cfr 820. in the eu
we have eduralx volume 4 annex 15
for pharmaceutical drugs as well as the
european medicines agency regulation for
medical devices
it's entitled ema regulation 2017-745
of the european parliament and the
council of the fifth of april 2017.
i've included a link to these documents
in my participant packet
and also iso 1345
so over the last 20 to 25 years we've
seen a movement from just
installation qualification operational
qualification
uh process qualification to risk-based
approaches for leveraging
factory acceptance testing site
acceptance testing
and design qualification and then
executing reduced
iqoq pq or ppq testing
once on-site some of these risk-based
approaches involve
gamp5 which is for gxp software systems
isp baseline guide 5
and the international council for
harmonization q8 quality by design
we're able to leverage these things in
order to take a risk-based approach to
validation activities
see the slide participant packets for
more regulatory information industry
guidance documents
and more so validation 101 the general
requirements
equipment should meet user specified
requirements and be designed constructed
located and installed for its intended
use
cleaning and maintenance equipment
should be regularly calibrated inspected
and or checked following a written
procedure including instrumentation
for calibration and or testing all
software must be validated before use
and all validation activities and
findings should be documented
i will point out that under item 1 the
manufacturers uh sorry under 0.2
all testing instrumentation being
calibrated pre and post validation
activities in order to mitigate risk
imagine if you found out three months
after your completed pq that your
temperature calibration failed
by having a pre and post calibration
right
bracketing either side of your
validation activities you mitigate that
risk and find out if you
have a problem at that time rather than
months down the road so validation 101
definitions
factory acceptance testing is
evaluational equipment during and after
the assembly process
at the manufacturer to verify that it is
built and operates in accordance with
design specifications
site acceptance testing is testing
according to client approved test plans
and test specifications to show a system
is installed and interfaces with other
systems
and peripherals in its working
environment and design qualification
describes the user requirements and
defines the functional and operational
specifications of this equipment
validation 101 definitions further has
iq
is the document that the system has the
required prerequisite conditions
to function as expected oq
documenting that the equipment
performance is consistent with the user
requirement specification
within the manufactured specified ranges
sometimes people will ask what if i
never intend to operate at the
manufacturer's limits of the equipment
this is a soft requirement it's always a
good idea to ensure that the equipment
that you've purchased
works as designed or that you get what
you're paying for in terms of capability
of the equipment
later if you don't do your operational
qualifications
at the limits of the manufactured
specified ranges
and later someone wants to use it at
those limits
they're going to have to re-qualify
because you did not cover the full range
so that can just save some time down the
road
and performance qualification documents
that equipment performance is
reproducible within the specific working
range and simulated real-world
conditions
so the general process for validating is
someone's going to
pre-approve an iqoq protocol
execute that protocol write their report
for their iqoq
and get their approvals then it goes on
to pq
if there's one required you need a
pre-approved protocol
execute that protocol write your report
and gain approvals for those as well
finally you're complete along the way
there's a handling of
lots of paper unless your company is uh
one of the ones that we'll talk about
later
so the validation 101 an iq summary
uh uniquely identified the equipment by
serial and or alcoholic asset id
many companies track these assets i
think valued over two thousand dollars
for depreciation reasons and there are
unique identifiers
that are used at most companies to help
track that asset
but is also used for identifying the
equipment
for validation
plan and document the placement of the
new equipment in relation to your
existing equipment
including your utility hookups
and you want to consider the impact of
your equipment on your room conditions
for something like an autoclave that
generates a lot of heat load
particularly when someone opens the door
at the end of a cycle and a lot of steam
is released
that can have a load on your hvac that
needs to be considered when you're
designing your facility
develop a plan for cleaning and
maintaining your equipment
specifying the version of software and
configuring it for the application
including backups
updating all plant drawings and
documentation to include your new
equipment
and conducting a pre-startup safety
review this last item
is not necessarily an fda regulation but
it's part of the other
regulated part of our industry which is
the occupational safety and
health administration osha and it's part
of
most companies employee health and
safety requirements
such as if i was installing a new
fermenter are there
heat or burn risks is there powder
generation is there a noise rating that
would require someone to be part of a
hearing conservation program
these are all usually rolled into iqoq
activities
at most companies for the oq summary we
have testing the components of your new
equipment and the entire system to
ensure they function as intended
testing the equipment at the
manufacturer's limits again as i pointed
out that's a soft requirement but you
might want to consider doing that to
make sure
the equipment operates as the
manufacturer designed
and that you catch it when you're
installing it not five years later when
you want
to all of a sudden qualify it at a a
wider range
testing alarms and their resulting
actions
and conducting any functional testing
such as temperature mapping
pressurization
this may be executed by either
validation personnel or operators in the
plant it depends on
conventions and procedures that you're
at your business but either validation
personnel or operators is acceptable
here
for pq summary test that the equipment
can operate consistently at normal
operating conditions for the user
requirements and functional
specifications
this may include using the number of
personnel and operators that will be in
the facility at the time
materials and commodities that are used
in manufacturing normally the
environmental conditions of temperature
humidity etc
that are required as well as using your
approved standard operating procedures
so i'm going to give an example of a
validation
a genetic analyzer since we're in the
middle of the pandemic
some of you may be familiar with some of
these genetic analyzers from
thermo fissure applied biosystems this
is the 3500 dx
series genetic analyzer it's a
fluorescence-based dna analysis
instrument using capillary
electrophoresis technology
and it consists of the instrument a
computer workstation and monitor
and integrated software
in this validation example this genetic
analyzer might have an iq consisting of
ensuring that the room can meet the
operating requirements and monitoring of
this room
the user's manual from the manufacturer
states that a 15 to 30 degrees c
range for temperature and less than a 2
degree c
variation during operation of the
instrument
20 to 80 percent humidity 9 condensing
calibrating a volt meter and checking
the receptacle to verify it meets the
electrical requirements of 100 to 240
volts
50 to 60 hertz and 50 amps verifying
identifying
the warranty and service contract or
alternatively if you have a calibration
group or maintenance group that
maintains instruments like this
there could be a check saying that that
has been put in place
verify that the product received matches
the product that you ordered
recording the make model serial number
asset id in the software version
verifying components have been unpacked
and positioned according to the
manufacturer's recommendations
and verifying that the instrument and
computer setup was according to the
installation service manual
training all instrument users and verify
or verifying that they do have training
already
so for the oq for the genetic analyzer
we would verify that the instrument
successfully powers on and that the led
indicators all function
record the operating system version
service pack and software version number
verifying all operating system and
software versions are compatible
verify that their laser power meter and
probe calibrations are valid
identifying array tools used to check
the instrument
verify subsystem including laser
capillary assembly polymer and buffers
and performing spectral calibration and
verifying that calibration meets the
specification
the pq might consist of identifying
calibration in standard materials
performing sequencing and fragment
analysis install performance checks
and verify that the check results meet
the acceptance criteria
so pre-pandemic paper-based workflow
many companies were not performing
digital papers validation prior to
pandemic
and we can see that
we would need to pre-approve an iqoq
protocol that's going to be word
processed
on a computer then
get that approved and execute that iqoq
protocol which is going to involve
someone manually filling out a paper
packet
and then scanning that copy into
the computer writing the report word
processing that
and assembling a validation package in a
binder of some sort
and then routing those for approvals
either using physical signature
and then scanning the material or a
digital signature via their
edms system if they have one so when we
when we scan items like this we also
need to verify that scanning process to
make sure there wasn't a misfeed
or a misaligned page and that all
materials were scanned and captured
there's some downsides here there's
a lot of time-consuming drafting time
routing protocol for report approvals
as well as assembling those binders
which involves
a lot of page stamping in my experience
and filling out
page numbers etc once the entire package
is collated
also during audit having a timely
retrieval of those packages can be
burdensome
it's difficult to maintain validation
integrity after completion
in my experience we've had pages lost
out of validation packages in our
validation library
plus the managing of printing
distribution and storage of these things
the stage is set now here we are in the
pandemic
we have no workers commuting or
traveling there everyone is suddenly
working remotely we had to rapidly
implement software solutions for remote
working such as
zoom as well as server traffic etc
people had to get different connectivity
solutions at their homes
there's a pressure to make progress on
our timelines
with these new restrictions in place or
should i say in spite of these new
restrictions
which lends us to virtual execution of
that paper workflow to continue
validation as best as we can
during the pandemic as the bare minimum
to keep up with work
that continues to flow through
so here we have a virtual execution of a
paper workflow
we still need to scan and upload our
paper validation files
organize and edit those files on company
servers
this is a familiar and with the existing
software but we're still processing lots
of paper
we still need personnel on site to
conduct our iq oq and pq activities
we're manually managing these tasks the
schedule compiling traceability matrices
and our validation master plan we must
ensure accountability for the approved
protocol
and the one executed copy
that one execution copy can be difficult
because
multiple people may print out the
execution copy
also not all employees had printers at
their homes to be able to do this
and someone would have to be at the
office to be able to execute
we also need to verify that scanning
process to ensure our data integrity
the virtual execution of this paper
workflow looks something like this
here's our pre-approved iqoq protocol
and we're word processing and saving
that
file now we're going to go execute
someone's going to manually fill that
out in the plant
and then scan that in and then we have
the iqoq report someone's going to word
process and assemble this validation
package and then we have our approvals
again
physically signing and scanning or using
digital signature video and ems
assembling that validation package while
under pandemic restrictions for the
workplace capacity
is problematic someone still has to go
into the office to do this
so accelerating validation with software
though
we can go from this virtual execution of
a paper workflow to stepping on the gas
and having a paperless software-based
validation solution
this gives us real-time view of project
schedule
easier to monitor control and improve
our validation processes
it builds a digital validation library
to reduce your future cycle time
it gives easy access to work from
previous project phases
and access to all validations anytime
and anywhere
it automatically will manage your
validation lifecycle if you pick the
right software
paperless software-based validation
solutions
computer access to software with cloud
storage will give us
the ability to edit those files within
that software
we can create all our protocols reports
within our software
we can execute our iqoq and pq remotely
leveraging on-site personnel
we can manage our tasks route for
approvals notify personnel
of open items and link all these
documents together
this can automatically generate the
traceability matrix for
your qualification documentation
the software solution makes the
validation process and activities
transparent and eliminates the needs to
manually create and maintain that
traceability
matrix by establishing links between
both documents as well as requirements
test cases and results items can be
tracked and subsequent actions assigned
to individuals
which facilitates compliance
paperless software-based validation
workflow looks like this
you can write in the software your iqoq
protocol and get it pre-approved through
the
automatic routing when it comes time to
execute you enter the results into the
software via the cloud
and then you have the software assist
you in writing
your reports then it routes for
approvals
which are routed in the software itself
and i should note that any deviations
or discrepancies or incidents that occur
during validation
have their own separate routing and
nesting into your final report
so let's take a look at a case study
pharmaceutical company a
pre-pandemic they had a pilot for
paperless validation at a single site
during the pandemic they tried to
continue this paper-based workflow at
all the other sites except for that
pilot
they were unable to maintain that
workload so they pivoted to a rapid
efficient rollout of paperless
validation workflow at all
their sites their training was sop based
just read and understand with optional
training videos
and the response has been very
enthusiastic everyone has embraced this
paperless validation workflow
i personally spoke with their director
of it quality and she had said prior to
the pandemic it was very difficult to
get any sites
to volunteer to trial or pilot
this uh new cloud software digital
validation solution
once the pandemic occurred and everyone
was at home
there was clamoring for rapid rollout
and everyone wanted to get on board
rapidly to help
deal with their work uh flow and their
workload
and still keep progress moving forward
so
how fast can you go yes can you go at
the same company
execution their validation remained the
same for both the paper and digital
execution
what has changed though is the software
prevents the user from
advancing to the next step without
completing an item or task
and putting their signature so basically
we have reduced
all the execution errors to zero this
eliminated 95
of their good documentation practice
errors that normally occur during paper
execution which translated
into a 15 to 20 time savings by
eliminating execution area
errors and not having the need to
collate paper validation packages at the
conclusion
paperless validation embeds the time
date and signature of the person
executing for each validation activity
again i spoke with the director of
quality quality here at this company
and she had said everyone is very
enthusiastic and is
in the groove of the new workflow and
can't believe that they used to do it
the old-fashioned paper way
the next case study i have is abby cork
ireland
they had an initial rollout for
commissioning qualification capabilities
only at a single site just cork ireland
now they're deploying globally across
all sites they have four sites online
with fifth over 15 scheduled in the next
year
they utilize the isp baseline guide 5
violin 5 approach and quality by design
deliverables
if you're familiar with that there is a
set of deliverables that comes with
quality by design
at that very end as you're doing your
risk assessment
the output is a control strategy and the
control strategy needs to be delivered
by the equipment
and so they needed to tie those
deliverables back to
what they're qualifying in each of their
pieces of equipment
they implemented the paperless
validation software for this risk-based
approach
and here is their statistics on their
time savings
so for their user requirement
specification approval cycle
pre-deployment it would take them two
months to get something
approved after deployment it was only
seven days which is an 88
time savings their site acceptance test
execution went from 30 hours to 14 hours
which is a 53 time savings and they're
creating their site acceptance testing
documentation
went from 30 hours to 20 hours so it's a
33
time savings this information for this
case study was provided by sol jarvis
from amv
so further more on their study they
prioritize these
important functions automated data
integrity
critical element and test tracing
automated requirements traceability
matrix that means if something changes
in the equipment specification it
automatically update that traceability
matrix without someone manually having
to do it
it would just rev up the version they
value user friendliness and ease of use
and validation reporting features such
as kpis for the validation status
their automated requirements
traceability matrix
has the quality by design critical
quality attributes and critical process
parameters
process risk assessment and control
strategy elements which tie to
qualification documents for testing
since the quality by design elements are
life cycle documents as they change this
may drive the
need for changes in the qualification
documents
their kpis for validation status
included
items such as protocols and draft
protocols routing
execution and progress etc
and they also had reports on issues and
deviations as one of their key
functions that they wanted the software
to have
additional benefits to paperless
validation include
streamlining your metrics and and having
data mining
expediting your protocol generation and
execution
improved response time during audits for
retrieval of packages
real-time review and monitoring of tasks
for validation
reducing your documentation errors
reducing the use of office supplies such
as paper and printer
toner cartridge and binders eliminating
the documentation
transportation and storage in your
validation library as well as your
validation librarian
and it maintains the order and
relationship of documents
the director of i.t quality at the
pharmaceutical company i spoke with
she said that by instituting a paperless
validation solution it allows them to
focus
on the actual work of validation
eliminating the manual labor related to
the workflow
and document management validation
personnel can
fully focus on the actual job of doing
the validation planning it
specifications testing and reporting
this facilitates compliance and reduces
the cost and cycle time for validation
overall
so software options i'm going to present
three that i reviewed
and looked for uh five validation has a
product called go5
neat solutions and val genesis
we'll take a look at each one one at a
time so five validation has a product
called go5
they were founded in 2019 and launched
their validation software the same year
gopher five validation is a validation
company that has developed their own
software for managing validation
paperwork
they in turn use their validation
software at their clients that
contract with them for validation work
and they use it for free just to show
them and test it out if the client is
willing
so they can see what paperless
validation might look like and whether
it's something that they would like to
to
use further their privately held company
and they have offices in sao paulo
brazil as well as boston massachusetts
they have 45 clients with 588 users
and they have as many as five site
deployments for one clark
client large that's the largest today
meet solutions was founded in 2007 and
launched their validation software in
2014
it had 14.48 million dollar private
investment in 2020 and a 16.63
million dollar investment in 2021.
they have offices in limerick ireland
norristown pennsylvania and halifax nova
scotia
and 14 of the top 20 global pharma
companies are their clients right now
they have 4 500 plus users across 75
plus client sites
bell genesis founded in 2005 and
launched their validation software
in 2009. they have 24 million dollars of
private equity financing received this
year in 2021
they have offices in south san francisco
tampa florida
toronto ontario shkupil netherlands
munich germany and chennai india they
have 88 clients with over 25 000
total users worldwide their clients
range from five to five thousand users
across one to fifty sites
software comparison chart all three
softwares are iso 9001 certified or iso
27 0001 certified
or in progress both of those iso
standards relate to
information security management and
software security
all of them are 21 cfr part 11 compliant
and they all have automatic backups i
would say it's worthwhile to inquire
about
the frequency and length of storage of
different backups
daily backups hourly backups etcetera
uh two of them automatically update your
validation master plan and two of them
have data management and reporting
software comparison chart shows template
lifecycle control standardization and
paperless text
execution automated deviation reports or
features
that all of them possess the ability to
execute offline is only offered by one
software
and i would say to just look into the
system software
functionality there carefully whether
you want or don't want that ability
to understand what the time date stamp
is
for your offline execution whether it's
your local time or a central server
one last software comparison chart
the ability to add attachments to
documents export to pdf
manage your workflow and have automation
and project lifecycle
automated traceability matrix are
features that all three software
packages
deliver for deployment from po being
placed until validation
in number of weeks fall genesis is six
to twenty weeks
meet solutions is four to sixteen for
go5 it's variable
it's going to depend on user needs and
requirements
so you should ensure that the types of
documents that you want
to use as attachments are supported by
each of the softwares that you might
consider using
whether it's jpeg png file etc
pdf to be able to attach that to your
doc
validation documents
comparing options for the virtual
execution of the paper workflow which
we're forced to do during the pandemic
we do have a familiar workflow and it's
easy to set up with existing software
the downsides though are that we have to
scan paper documents and validate
or verify that scanning process manually
sort virtual files
creating a traceability matrix by hand
and then
the risk of losing executed copies and
if you don't have an edms system you are
still compiling binders of information
and having to store them in a validation
library
if we move to the paperless
software-based validation
the improvements are built in data
integrity with action
log an automatic traceability matrix
generation
real-time progress monitoring of our
schedule and our validation activities
automated workflow and automated issuing
of deviation
reports issues reports from your your
execution
the only downsides i could say are it
still is a new software and new
workflows that require configuration
training and validation of that software
and it also requires someone to be on
site for the physical
inspections and tasks for your
validation you can leverage
someone holding a webcam or an ipad or
something like that
to be able to hold it up and have
someone remotely
checking off the items that are
completed in the
execution copy of your protocols but um
it does require still to have someone on
site
so are you ready to accelerate paperless
validation
is still a computerized system
validation you need to validate
the software so you're going to need
user requirements including security
and functional specifications before
pursuing software options
some of the functionality for security
you should consider is unauthorized
access
either internally or externally data
record destruction either accidental or
intentional data and record modification
either inappropriate
altering of your data and unauthorized
usages both
internally and externally uh you can use
these user requirements and functional
specifications to create your own
comparison table
of any software vendors that you
consider for
paperless validation factor in the
project cost of your software licensing
support
training and maintenance consider a
single site beta test rollout
for rolling out to other locations
that's all i have uh if you have any
questions feel free to contact me
and it was a pleasure presenting to you
ways of accelerating
validation during the pandemic